a furtive great one on a lake of mud. A tall beast with invisible projectiles
Tens of never before seen
enemies and pages of untold lore. The cut content of Bloodborne has finally been laid bare for us
And so to quote Micolash: "Let us sit about and speak feverishly
Chatting till the wee hours
of my wonderful nightmare!"
*screams manically *
Ok Micolash calm down first the cut bosses revealed by Zullie the witch so those tentacles
Clawing at you through the fog, and that's the first sign that you're not supposed to be here
Well that and the doorway to nothingness behind you
Upon entering your emerge onto this muddy coastline
Which is very reminiscent of the orphan's arena, except this place
also has the sinking architecture of the chalice dungeon which is really Lovecraftian if you've read his work and
A few of you may have realized already what this thing is. Take a look at its face
It's the moon presence, though not as we know it. This form it's in is this flailing mess of a creature
That's barely capable of standing upright
I think you can even see its heart sort of hanging loosely below it in this exposed ribcage
It's really weak though. You can see echoes of its former
Glory when it lifts itself up off the ground like this
And you know what I think this thing is? I think it might be the physical form of the moon presence
preserved in the chalice dungeons as opposed to the
consciousness of the moon presence that we fight in the hunter's dream
At the chalice dungeons after all are home to the slumbering Great Ones and
Some of these labyrinths are in contact with the cosmos, which allows the Great Ones to function and I quote on
"On transcendental plains of thought."
Many Great Ones ascended long ago
And as we know these beings up above
in the nightmares they no longer have a need for their body in the physical plane
And it would make some sense for the moon presence's physical body to still be down here
But regardless it's clearly a very undeveloped boss fight
And it's quite easy as a result which kind of suits its appearance really, kind of like King Allant's
true form in Demon Souls, but anyway speaking of
incomplete bosses, this creature
Currently going by the name Great One Beast is this far more agile
monster than many of the other large bosses you would have fought in Bloodborne
And I think it would have made for a great fight as a result. It has similar moves to Sif and many other wolf-like
enemies in souls and just look at that face. It really reminds me of the Dragon God from Demon Souls
The Great One Beast, would this have been a Great One that contracted the plague of beasts
Or would it be a Great One that started the plague perhaps?
There's not much else to say here and lastly a fight with not one wet nurse nor two
But three wet nurses. Zullie, who is the chalice dungeon's host
They mused on whether this is an issue with their illusions spawning
But not going away or whether this was just meant to be a multi enemy boss fight
It's a bit of a mess either way and speaking of Mergo's wet nurse, after you defeated her in the main game
The hunter's workshop is set ablaze, you recall. Well in Gehrman's cut content
He has a very interesting response to this turn of events
"We've no need for this accursed abode."
"Let flame cleanse this house of horrors."
"These frightful things, look at them burn."
"All ye hunters let it be known, we're free,"
"Free, as the wind."
"Laurence, the end is not far away now,"
"Every last dream will burn out and Flora will return from the moon."
"As for us,
The time has come to honor our vows."
Hunters are needed no longer
You and I shall fight to the death
And she will consume the victor, the way we've always said we'd end it you recall
Oh Laurence,
Of course you remember." There's so much information here, though
There is only really one solid piece of information we can take from this cut content in my opinion
and it's that the moon presence is called Flora as
We had previously guessed. The rest of Gehrman's cut dialogue is a bit contradictory with his in-game dialogue
First, Gehrman celebrates the burning of the workshop, stating that hunters are free, free as the wind
But in the actual game Gehrman would have remained bound to the dream even after it burned out
Which is evidenced by the fact that the dream continues even after we take his place?
So hunters really freed?
Second in the cut content. It seems that Laurence and Gehrman were
Originally supposed to fight, fight for the right to be consumed by Flora. That's weird
Gehrman and Laurence always struck me as really ambitious characters and look at what they started and look at what they achieved
in Yharnam
It doesn't really fit to me for these old friends to fight to the death
For the right to be eaten
I can see why this might have been cut. What is more in line with
Gehrman's story is this next bout of dialogue because it seems that at one point
Gehrman was far more vocal about his willingness to leave the nightmare and about what will happen when he does
What were you thinking?
if I die
You are to be next
What is it you want from this horrific nightmare?
What?
Looking to free me?
Then I graciously accept
forgive me Laurence, I could not wait
In game, they ended up making Gehrman far more reluctant to give up the dream
which I really like because it speaks to his strong sense of martyrdom and
Self-sacrifice, but what still remains unclear in the main game and even in all of this cut content after all this time
I think, is
what Gehrman hoped to achieve in the Hunter's Dream and
What he's waiting for Laurence to achieve in the outside. Do you remember this line of dialogue?
" Oh, Laurence. What's taking you so long
I've grown too old for this of little use now, I'm afraid." That's not cut content,
That's in the game Lawrence first vicar and founder of the healing church
was supposed to do something in the waking world while Gehrman was in the dream the question is what and
the answer at least at one point might have been
ministration. Writer DMCRedgrave
Who is one of the best analysts of Bloodborne lore once wrote that
Gehrman is desperate for Laurence and the art of blood ministration to find someone who can put an end to the nightmare
Who can find a Paleblood strong enough to become immune to the taint of the Great Ones
So with the revelation that Gehrman might have been waiting specifically for the effects of Laurence's blood
ministration, it appears that
Redgrave may well have been right. His Paleblood hunt document will be the first link in the description
it's one of the best resources on Bloodborne story to date as many of you already know but to those of you who don't
Do yourself a favor and set aside a couple of hours to read it all. Of course there could be other reasons
Gehrman is waiting for the effects of Laurence's blood ministration for example
Laurence's Beast's Embrace Rune shows that he was trying to control the scourge of beasts and
maybe ministration was a way of doing that and
Also the Metamorphosis Rune also speaks of how their discovery of blood made their dream of evolution a reality
So perhaps Gehrman was waiting for ministration to achieve these things as well, but it's been years
And I'm not sure if we'll ever know for sure and as it turns out the one who
Administers blood to us in the opening cutscene
Originally had more to him as well
"Welcome weary traveler, to the great city of Yharnam"
"The troubles you must have seen. Your homeland plagued by a sickness that spares few"
You suffer your loved ones suffer. It's like a curse
But there is hope for you yet
the blood used in
ministration. The trade of Yharnam is a special thing indeed the only thing that can cure your sickness
Interesting to note the mention of a plague afflicted homeland outside of Yharnam
And that blood was a trade of Yharnam suggesting that blood might have made its way out of the city
These things are especially relevant if we're getting an extension of this world in "shadows die twice"
And it seems also that you were supposed to exchange a few lines of dialogue with the minister after the transfusion
Woken up with something of a nightmare have you? A foul murky story?
Quite beyond my own reckoning and there be something to tell the grandkids
Hey, *chuckles*
Oh but I have nothing more to tell I only show the way
The way has been shown, no?
It's in your hands until the dank sweet, mud
Takes us all
upon the awakening of Ebrietas
Upon the awakening of Ebrietas
Ebrietas is fairly central to the story as it is this Great One who works together with the choir
looking to the skies in search of astral signs which may lead them to the rediscovery of true greatness
As the quote-unquote "left behind Great One." It seems that Ebrietas did not ascend with her kin
And so its awakening might have originally been more important to the story
Anyway, it also appears that you could kill this Blood Minister. If you so desired
Revealing that Yharnam may well exist in a sort of pocket dimension as expected
My death
That is not
It's your nightmare
after all
But the thing I want to talk about is that in the cut content
there's this common theme of characters being far more aware of the dreams that they actually reside within
I like the information this provides because now we've heard Gehrman mused about his capture within his hunter's dream
we've heard Micolash brag about his new real world and
So too do we hear Maria lament our progress through the nightmare of the old hunters?
"Hmm, a visitor
How unexpected
Then the secrets of the church had been laid bare
Good hunter
Lost in the nightmare. What did you think of that beast the legend and those ailing Ward's of the church?
I know what you did to them
It's not your fault
The nightmare held them
And now they are free." This beastly legend she refers to could be
Ludwig or Laurence though Ludwig is closer and within her building. She mentions the
Ailing Ward's of the church to which would have been her patience in the research hall that you killed up to this point
Interesting also to note again that dying in a nightmare is a way to be set free something
That's reinforced in the base game with Micolash:
"Now I'm waking up! I'll forget everything!"
And with Gehrman: "Be freed from the night."
Maria then tries to coax us out of the nightmare: "But what about you?
Have you profited at all?" If you answer
Yes, she commends you and she tries to gently lure you out of the nightmare with yet more profit to tide you over
remember Maria is likely here far more wilfully than the other hunters cursed to remain in this nightmare as
There are signs that she has a lot of guilt about what the hunters did here in the Fishing Hamlet
So if you answer yes, I have profited from being here. "Oh really?
Well, that's a relief
Now you can leave this nightmare have respect for the beast hunter Gehrman's wishes
Besides, you will not find your enemies here. Take the relics in this room as your parting prize
Let them be your strength and
Return to your hunt, good hunter"
It's so curious that she says that Gehrman wouldn't want you to progress further perhaps because the events here were what led to
His beloved Maria's death. If you answer no, I haven't profited enough from this nightmare
her tone is far more wary because basically you're saying you're not satisfied and
This indicates you may well want more from this nightmare."I thought as much
Nightmares and secrets. They'll only get you so far
Now you can leave this place." You could argue that a lot of this dialogue is redundant
But I love how this fleshes out her character and her tone especially the bits where she says good hunter like the doll
Yes, it's cut content
But it's not the kind of cut content that contradicts with what we already know
This was likely removed as a stylistic choice as they probably wanted the original cutscene to be shorter and more punchy
"What's wrong my hunter?
Don't you hear the hunt calling or do you wish to tease something more from the depths of this nightmare?
even if it means my murder
Hmm, look at you, that glint in your eyes
You girl are insufferable
Oh I know very well
How the secrets beckon so sweetly
Only an honest death will cure you now
Liberate you from your wild curiosity"
And there's a lot more dialogue than this that I haven't put in this video because I haven't got around to extracting it yet
And not only that but you need to check out everything in the description because down there are videos by people capable of
Extracting never-before-seen assets and character models from the game as well
There has been some really amazing work done in the last few weeks
And it's awesome the game this old can get so much fresh blood so to speak
You should also check out the Bloodborne
remixes by Alex Roy the perfectly tweaked
soundtrack which is a perfect backdrop to this video about cut content
I say, there's a lot, but this description box is full of some really good stuff
So don't neglect it
patrons will get access to my notes on the cut content that I haven't mentioned in this video as a thank you to everyone who's
Pledged to the beacon tier and above. But to lead us out. I'll pass over to Gascoigne whose cut dialogue has
Interesting implications for the next video which is going to tie all of the SoulsBorne storylines together.
"Sick creature
May you rest in peace, Umbasa."
I'll see you soon